just last summer paul pelosi placed a
bet of up to six million dollars on big
tech giants that was ahead of a house
committee moving forward with an
anti-trust bill aimed at silicon valley
titans and it's all just the latest bit
bad news
for the couple as you might recall paul
pelosi recently charged with dui out in
napa after a may car crash and speaker
pelosi continues to see her party in as
much disarray as ever as democrats now
face major losses in the house in
november likely putting her out of power
here with reaction the book couldn't be
more timely maybe the best book he's
ever written and that's defeating big
government socialism uh and how to
protect the country fox news contributed
newt gingrich by the way tomorrow night
newt will have a live signing of his
book 5 pm eastern right here on while on
his facebook page let me go back to this
this quote exactly so
their answer is the speaker doesn't own
any uh stocks and that the transactions
are for the spouse and she had no
knowledge or suffered involvement and
then they say
um you should check with the committee
on the latest
uh why is that not an adequate response
to me the question is did she give him
insider information that caused him to
invest in the stocks because that would
be at least where i grew up that would
be considered something like oh insider
trading
yeah i'm going to probably surprise you
a little bit here sean
i think there's an enormous difference
between paul pelosi and hunter biden
paul pelosi is a very sophisticated
businessman he's been around a long time
he's been investing for over 50 years
you know he reads the wall street
journal the financial times he talks to
smart people the bet he made was a minor
bet in terms of his fortune uh and i to
the best of my knowledge there was no
particular insider advantage there's not
it's not a particular company that's
particularly advantaged if that happened
you're exactly right that'd be insider
trading and that's clearly a felony and
people can go to jail for it but i
suspect it's just common knowledge i've
known from as you have for months now
that the house and senate democrats are
slugging their way through on a actually
pretty bipartisan basis trying to get
this chip bill through to compete with
china so paul saw that the difference
between paul pelosi is a serious
financial guy
and
what we see with hunter biden which is
just pure corruption
uh i think is enormous and and if i were
going to focus on
uh big government socialism i would
start with
the president releasing the american
oil reserve and having a million barrels
go to a chinese company with a
relationship with the president's son
now that to me is a clear open and shut
scandal and probably impeachable offense
i'm not particularly defending paul
although he is a very smart businessman
but i don't when i read the story i
don't automatically get a problem that
there's some kind of insider trading or
insider deal if if the last name with
trump i think we'd be having a very
different narrative in the country right
now just just my little take
you know i i think we both agree that
it's the likelihood is very high
republicans will take back the house
i feel pretty strongly that that's going
to be a slam dunk but when you look at
for example
republicans have to hold north carolina
pennsylvania wisconsin they've got to
hold ohio
those are all bellwether states and
missouri that's another one and then
you're looking for pickups in georgia
which has had
intra-party turmoil somewhat i think
herschel would be a great senator
uh but they've been going after him with
a vengeance we might put states like new
hampshire colorado and washington state
and play but then we've got nevada then
we've got arizona um then we've got you
know
all these other states potentially we
could do well in on paper republicans
should win based on the economy but i'm
not buying into that this is going to be
a cakewalk your thoughts
well i think it depends entirely on the
republicans if the republicans go big
they're going to crush the democrats
georgia's a great example if the
republicans go small and let it
degenerate into a fight between herschel
walker as a person and warnock as a
person then it's i think an up in the
air kind of race warnock's a
professional preacher a very articulate
guy he has an amazing amount of money
but if warnock's got to carry biden
and nine percent inflation and a
doubling of the gas price and all the
people coming across the border and the
rising crime rate warnock's just going
to drown so you go across the country as
you just did and i can easily see a
circumstance where if republicans play
it stupid
they could end up picking up maybe one
or two net still still a majority but
one or two but if they play it smart if
every single race you described becomes
a choice between the biden candidate who
is killing america and the republican
alternative i think you could see them
sweep every state remember
when when i worked with ronald reagan in
1980 we did the first capital steps
event we had the first contract we
picked up 14 senate seats
not because our candidates were
brilliant we won five of them by a
combined total of 75 000 votes why
because they had a wave coming an
american wave not a republican wave an
american wave we get that american wave
this fall uh you're going to be shocked
how big the republican majority in the
senate is if there's anybody that's
running for office listening to you now
that doesn't get on the phone and call
you and ask
very specifically what they should be
doing they're all idiots that's my
advice to all of them to call you i'll
give out your number do you mind 202. oh
sorry
you know i have it memorized so i could
do it all they've got to do is i just
all they're going to do is play this
episode i just laid out what they need
to do
okay
make it a big election about big issues
and your book actually outlines it and
it's very timely that is the best advice
the simplest advice buy the book
the next thing they need to do is by the
way mean it and do it when they get
elected that's a big part of the
equation also that's right all right
speaking about this should be a contract
of some kind this fall
agree
mccarthy says he's doing it in the house
the senate needs to do it as well i
don't know what mitch mcconnell's going
to do in the senate let's agree let's
just get over with mcconnell should do
it in the senate too
all right mr speaker defeating big
government socialism amazon.com
hannity.com bookstores all around the
country hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else